What kind of TV shows do you like to watch?
I'm not really into TV all that much.
My parents always called it the "Idiot Box" and I kind of agree with them.
Yeah, I know what you mean.
Still, I find myself watching it more often than I'd like to admit.
Sure, I can understand that.
It can be pretty addicting.
I really like watching reality shows.
You know, like "Survivor" and stuff like that.
Oh sure, I guess they can be a little more interesting.
Exactly, hence the name!
I prefer watching real people to actors.
I feel that I can relate to them better somehow.
Yes, and the fact that everything is more natural, and not scripted,...
...makes them a bit better.
It sounds like you still don't watch them very often.
You're right.
There are too many other things I'd rather be doing than watching TV.